[Musique]
ce dont nous sommes témoins ici c'est le
retour des titans
[Musique]
combien il y en a partout elles sont 17
husky si on est mal barré
[Musique]
m'ôtera redonne guide aura
et se déplacent comme une meute il ça se
ils sont tous soumis aux ordres d'un
mâle alpha
si on arrête ce qui donnera on les
arrête tous y at il une autre créature
qui aurait une chance contre lui
[Musique]
gossip
notre planète a péri
et nous avec lui
à mois que nous libérions quand il
[Musique]
c'est ça on peut aussi lui offrir une
bière non cette fois on va se joindre au
combat
[Musique]
figé
c'est le moine de godzilla nous ne
faisons qu y vivre c'est évident